his work was legendary his literary work
showed signs of brilliance and his
lifestyle made him for a time amongst
the most celebrated artists of his age
yet his spectacular fall was
unprecedented only equals in modern
times by the disaster that was OJ
Simpson oh yes in this week's by
graphics we are diving into the
outrageous life of the self-proclaimed
genius Oscar Wilde
Oscar Fingal a flat he wills wild into
the world on October the 16th 1854 the
flamboyance of his name was a portent of
things to come his parents they were
socially prominent Anglo Irish
Protestants each with a collective
interests a belief in national politics
and a publishing career of their own
Oscar's father William was a renowned
physician specializing in the iron ear
he was a slight unkempt figure with an
ugly beard and a roving eye but this
absolutely did not stop him carrying on
numerous Affairs throughout his marriage
and he fathered several illegitimate
children in contrast to her husband
though Oscars mother Jane was especially
elegant and statuesque she was almost 6
feet tall and towered over her husband's
she was a woman who longed to make a
sensation one stating that I should like
to rage through life this Orthodox
creeping is to tame the meme and well
you probably guessed that this was the
attitude that her son would quickly
embrace when Oscar her second son was 8
months old
Jane described him as a great stout
creature who Minds nothing but growing
fat Jane had actually wanted a girl in a
set to have dressed Oscar and treated
him as a daughter for the first decade
of his life at age 9 Oscar along with
his older brother Willie was sent to his
first school the portora royal boarding
school in anis killin far in the
protestant north of Ireland Oscar was
younger than most of his peers though at
first he was eclipsed by his older
brother but by the time that Willie was
set to leave port Ora he had been
superseded academically by Oscar in fact
the younger Wilde was intellectually far
ahead of his classmates in 1889 he
recalls I was looked upon as a prodigy
by my associates because quite
frequently I word for a wager read a
three-volume novel in half an hour
so closely as to be able to give an
accurate resume of the plot of the story
by one hours reading I was enabled to
give a fair narrative of the incidental
scenes and the most pertinent dialogue
in 1871 Wilde won a scholarship to study
classics at Trinity College Dublin he
arrived at in 1873 at the age of 18
there he was tutored and befriended by
Reverend John Pentlands Mohave professor
of ancient history Mahaffey inspired his
pupil to be proficient in Greek and in
1875 he won the prestigious Berkeley
gold medal in Greek three years later in
1874 Oscar sail to England to take the
examination for a classics scholarship
at Oxford University while awaiting the
results he went to London and was
dazzled by his first taste of the
metropolis after that he traveled to a
nother metropolis and that was Paris it
was there with his mother and brother
that he received news that he had won
his scholarship and had not only won it
but it achieved the highest mark of the
entire group Oscar he absolutely made
the most of his time at Oxford it was
during this time that he cultivated his
aesthetic sensibilities filling his room
with lilies and spending vast portions
of his father's money upgrading the deck
or of his room it was at this time that
he famously said I find it harder and
harder every day to live up to my Blue
China while he was never a fan of sport
but he did enjoy watching others play
crickets and also run he developed a
reputation for his wisps proclaiming
that the only possible exercises to talk
not to walk still he was absolutely no
pusher it is believed that once while in
his room for undergraduates pounced on
him to beaten up and smash his
belongings while he said to have kicked
out the first interloper punched the
second as he doubled over hurled the
third through the air and carried the
last back to his own room and then
tossed him on the floor now it was
during his time at Oxford that Wiles
became a Mason he adopted the costume
velvet breeches tail coat white tie and
silk hose that his extravagant lifestyle
it was ultimately dented in April of
1876 when his father died leaving a
serious debt behind Oscar though he
still managed to find a way to indulge
himself with semester holidays around
Europe just prior to his graduation in
1878 he consoled his mother distraught
with financial worry that we have genius
that is something attorneys can't take
away Oscar he emerged from Oxford with a
degree and a clear vision of what was in
store in a remarkably prophetic
a couple of sentences he declared God
knows I won't be a dried-up Oxford dawn
anyhow I cannot live without desire fear
and pain self poised self centered and
self comforters obviou poet a writer a
dramatist somehow or other I'll be
famous and if not famous notorious in
December of 1878 while that moved to
London he shared a flat with Frank miles
a fellow Oxford graduate during this
time he was introduced to many writers
artists and actors he soon gained a
reputation for his wit and became a
favorite dinner guest where he would
espouse his aesthetic values he applied
for various fellowships and even tried
to become an inspector of schools during
all of this he was working on his first
play Vera which he privately printed in
1880 Vera was a story of noble socialism
set in 19th century Russia but
unfortunately for Wilde the New York and
London producers that he sent the play
to they turned it down
in 1881 Oskar published 61 pieces of
writing under the title poems an initial
run of 750 copies it sold out with to
further printing runs being required
meanwhile during all of this a play by
the renowned team of Gilbert & Sullivan
was indirectly making world famous it
was called patience and it was a Lampoon
of the aesthetic culture that Wilde
epitomized the main character was
clearly modelled on him by June of 1881
while satyrs would such that the Prince
of Wales commented I do not know mr.
Wilde and not to know mr. Wiles is not
to be known
despite this ever growing reputation
Wilde found himself in tough financial
straits he was offered and accepted a
series of lecture tours around America
to coincide with the New York opening of
patience he set sail on Christmas Eve
1881 to instruct the new world in the
English art of Renaissance on arrival he
told the New York customs officer I have
nothing to declare but my genius but
don't try this today anyone well the
Americans they were absolutely
fascinated by him and the original
schedule was to be extended repeatedly
in order to meet public demands it would
last almost a year and it would even
extend to Canada financially he did very
very well out of this tour he actually
stayed in New York for two months after
the tour's end he then briefly returned
to London in January of 1883 before
relocating to Paris where he immersed
himself in artistic circles it was at
this point that he made himself /
physically he had his long flowing locks
transformed into a bull haircut and took
to wearing a black overcoat this was
increased contrast to the flamboyant
colors that he was previously known for
in May of 1883 Wilde returned to London
apparently motivated by his interest in
a woman named Constance Lloyd the
daughter of a prosperous London lawyer
for the last few years despite his
American earnings as Oscar have certain
money worries the right marriage would
also solve those problems while also
answering the growing gossip about his
sexual character a year-long courtship
followed with the marriage taking place
on the 29th of May 1884 the couple they
honeymooned in Paris and then thanks to
his new father-in-law's money occupied a
four-story house in London he then went
ahead
and had the place redecorated at huge
expense which plunged the newlyweds into
immediate debt wilds first child Cyril
was born on the 5th of June 1885 with
Vivian following on November the 5th
1886 with his writing career going
nowhere he agreed to a British lecture
tour with topics such as the value of
art in modern life lecturing and other
invitations they kept him away from his
family home a lot and during these long
absences he began to surround himself
with young men writing unguardedly of
his infatuation with the beauty of the
male form he formed an especially close
friendship with a 17-year old named
Robby Ross
during the late 1880s while bringing him
money with occasional book reviews Wilde
works on his first novel the Picture of
Dorian Gray when the book was published
in a magazine in 1890 it caused an
immediate scandal the storyline involved
a subtly a Rotter sized triangle of
relationships between three men and it
was condemned by many as being immoral
Walt had predicted such an outcome
having written the following in the
preface there is no such thing as a
moral or immoral book books are well
written or badly written that is all it
was around this time the wild was
introduced to a blonde fair-skinned
undergraduate by the name of Lord Alfred
Douglass but he was known to his
intimates as boy see Oscar quickly
became obsessed with the 22 year olds
from this time on Oscar saw Constance
and his children less often he did
writings from rented addresses or hotels
usually with Boise and tome boy sees
father was actually the Marquis of
Queensbury yep the man who developed the
rules of professional boxing he took an
immediate and intense exception to the
relationship between his son and the
famous Wilde
apart from the sexual aspect of their
relationship Queensbury was enraged that
Wilde was distracting his son from his
studies at Oxford when Boise quit his
studies in May of 1893 the Marquis
became determined to bring Wilde down
but it was around this time that Wilde
finally achieved success on the stage a
woman of no importance opened on April
the 19th 1893 to widespread acclaim
during its run it brought him between a
hundred and seventy and two hundred
pounds per week his next play the satire
and ideal husband was also successful
providing the means for Oscar and Boise
to travel widely and live extravagantly
the Marquis of Queensbury thought his
son's failure to take his degree in
Oxford was a scandalous waste of time he
placed the blame squarely at the feet of
Wilde referring to the relationship as
the most loathesome and disgusting
Queensbury began absolutely hounding the
path he actually even threatened to
disinherit Boise so this the son replied
with a telegram what a funny little man
you are Queensbury no surprisingly
didn't like this one bit and on the 19th
of June Queensbury burst in on Wilde at
his tithes street address in London he
had a bodyguard with him and proceeded
to threaten bodily harm unless the
relationship ended media
so what was Boise's reaction to all of
this well he wrote nonchalantly to his
father I write to inform you that I
treat your absurd threats with absolute
indifference the encounter though it's
unsettled wild who got out of London for
several months going on a holiday with
his family to Worthing this is where he
worked on his latest play The Importance
of Being Earnest but it wasn't before
Boise unable to stay away invited
himself along as you might imagine this
caused a little bit of tension between
mr. and mrs. wild The Importance of
Being Earnest opens to great applause on
February the 14th 1895 two weeks later
it was already a wild success and in
true oscar wilde style
he began basking in the glow of this it
was at this point that Wilde called in a
de lavish Albemarle Club there he was
handed a card from Queensbury by a
porter on this card was scrawled to
Oscar Wilde posing sodomite at Boise's
urging Wilde went to Marlborough Street
police station to ask for a warrants for
Queens breeze rest on the grounds of
libel the case games trial on April the
3rd prosecuting counsel Edward Carson
put on the stand a 16 year old rent boy
who claimed had been paid for sex by
Wilde Carson then went on to dissect
works published by Wilde revealing their
supposed homosexual undertones so how
did Wilde react to this rather serious
event well he chose to wield his
celebrated wit as his main defensive
tool he was often funny but the implicit
superiority in his position
it was also damaging in oneexchange when
Carson asked whether the affection and
love that his portrayed and the Picture
of Dorian Gray might lead an ordinary
individual to believe it had a solder
medical tendency Oscar replied I have no
knowledge of the ordinary individual
which didn't exactly endear him to
anyone wilds counsel Edward Clark also
made serious miscalculations that did
his clients no favors
he went over letters of the Queensbury
had sent his son in attempt to show how
crazed the father had become to the jury
though Queens breeze volatility was
driven by a paternal regard for Boise's
character as Carson put it his clients
had one hope alone and that was simply
saving his son on the third day of
proceedings with things not exactly
going brilliantly wiles he chose not to
attend this was to prove them
damaging day yet with Carson announcing
that he intended to introduce a number
of boys who would testify to shocking
act performed by Oscar now without
consulting his clients wilds lawyer
Clark offered to abandoned the case the
defense however insisted that the
original plea stands the judge agreed
and compelled an acquittal from the jury
Queensbury he was found not guilty of
libel against Wilde it had now been
proven that his written accusation of
sodomy was not libelous but now there
was another important consequence it
left wild highly vulnerable to arrest
for sodomy which was a crime at that
time in England and well this is exactly
what happens at 5:00 in the evening of
the day the libel case was decided a
summons was issued for the arrest of
Oscar Wilde the charge was committing
acts of gross indecency hiding in the
Cadogan hotel Oscar was urged by Boise
and others to take a boat immediately
for France even his wife told him to run
however this just didn't sit right with
wiles he was determined to stand his
ground and declaring I shall stay and do
my sentence whatever it is at 6:10 p.m.
two detectives arrived and took a semi
drunk wild to Bow Street station the
arrest of Oscar Wilde caused an absolute
sensation any friends that he still has
quickly drifted away both of his
currently running place they were
canceled and his name very quickly
became toxic Wilde was kept in a Cell in
Bow Street which was then Holloway
prison Queensbury now administered the
low blow of forcing a bankruptcy sale of
Oscars belongings helped by a long list
of angry creditors by this time Wilde
was about $6,000 in debt after making
sure that oscar had nothing of any
physical value left Queensbury wrote to
a newspaper denying that he was capable
of any sympathy for Wilde he stated I
have helped to cut up and destroy sharks
I have no sympathy for them but I felt
sorry and wish to put them out of pain
as fast as possible the trial well I ran
from the 26th to the 29th of April it
was extraordinarily explicit in its
allusions to sexual acts many coming
from the young men who claimed to have
been partakers various savoy hotel
employees testified that they had seen
boys in wilds bed however Oscars counsel
was able to point out contradictions in
testimonies especially those of the
Rennes boys this'll meant that the jury
they were unable to reach a verdict
but Wilde he was not out of the woods as
a normal
immediate retrial began between the two
trials he did manage to secure bail
though stiff conditions were imposed he
tried to stay at a number of hotels only
to be told to teach that he was
unwelcome he finally managed to find
lodgings with his brother Willie the
second trial began on May the 22nd at
the Old Bailey this time after two hours
of discussion the jury returned with a
verdict of guilty the sentence would be
two years of hard labor wilde was taken
to Pentonville prison the wooden bed in
his cell has sheets and rugs but no
mattress at impasse was provided for his
toilet the prison clothes they were also
not exactly his accustomed style of
dress wilde was also compelled to walk
on a treadmill senselessly for six hours
each day and allowed to exercise
outdoors for one hour
he was also forced to make postal bags
for three whole months he had no outside
contact and after that things were not
much better with him only being allowed
to write one letter the regime was
absolutely brutal while recalling three
punishments authorized by law hunger
insomnia and illness in September of
1895 he received a visit from Constance
who found the experience awful more so
than any conception of it could be
Constance reported that Wiles professed
a rejection of his former conduct and
begged her for forgiveness for his
madness during the last three years she
decided to stand by her week rather than
wicked spouse still she abandoned his
name referring to herself as Constance
Holland when Boise heard about Oscars
rejection of his former lifestyle he was
heartbroken
he wrote I am NOT in prison but I think
I suffer as much as Oscar and in fact
more that was probably not the case
though because I mean prison
it was obviously pretty rough in October
he actually came down with dysentery
then on November the 21st he was
transferred to Redding prison at Clapham
Junction station it was spat on and
ridiculed by the crowds here though
conditions they were improved and his
duties they were lighter he was finally
released on May the 19th 1896 Oscar was
booked into the hotel sandwich in Dieppe
in northern France living off the
generosity of the few friends who had
stood by him by now Constance had
decided on divorce and suffering herself
with spinal prale
this had put off any reunion between
June and July of 1897 Oscar wrote his
last major work The Ballad of reading
jail
the subjects well that was underlining
the need for reform in Britain's prison
and justice system's lightened yep it
was excruciatingly ly lonely for Oscar
society at large shuns him and he spent
day after day alone and miserable
finally his resolve collapsed and he
rode to Boise inviting him to come and
stay they reconciled on August the 28th
with wild bursting into tears at the
sight of his one true love when
Constance heard of her husband's
behavior she wrote to him forbidding any
return to your filthy insane life when
he refused to give up Boise she cut him
off completely once the initial passions
subsided it became clear that both wild
and Boise were different than their
pretrial selves Boise he felt a duty to
help wild but this was no longer tied to
love on December the 3rd Boise left for
Naples and did not return Oscar's last
two years mostly in Paris they were
pitiful
he drank hired men and begged
acquaintances they were few constants
Holland's sadly died aged 40 after an
operation on her back on April the 7th
1898 then in April 1900 miles went with
an acquaintance named Harold Miller to
Rome where he received the Pope's
blessing a month later he was in Paris
and suffering from ill health which he
attributed to food poisoning his skin
was irritable and then frequently came
out in rashes by September he was
completely bedridden on October the 10th
he was operated upon for an ear
infection the operation it did not go
well and he got worse
still he did insist on continuing to
drink absinthe and champagne on November
the 25th a diagnosis of acute inoperable
cerebral meningitis was reached from
here on Oscar drifted in and out of
consciousness and leave insanity at
half-past five the following morning a
death rattle began minutes after his
demise his body actually sort of
exploded through it pouring out of
several orifices Oscar Wilde well he
died as he had lived inappropriately
rage' Slee and with scant reference to
water decorum demanded so I really hope
you found that video interesting if you
did please do hit that thumbs up button
below and do not forget to subscribe for
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday we've got loads of other people
just like this also check out a couple
of videos from the archives over there
on the right and as always
thank you for watching hello again just
jumping in real quick to add something
now that that video was over obviously
this is recorded later we want to get
your opinion on something we've made
some t-shirts that go along with this
video we're thinking about doing it for
other bhaiyya graphics that we put
together please do check out the link in
the description below we've got some
t-shirts with oscar wilde quotes on them
do check it out let us know what you
think in the comments we'd love to hear
from you and whether you'd like to see
more stuff like that and again thanks
for watching